hey 42 here the least common pin number
is eight zero six eight welcome to RIF
to make them less conspicuous white
horses in the British Army during the
First World War were dyed brown with
food coloring the world's smallest
advert was stenciled on to a bee's knee
the caffeine extracted from decaf coffee
is sold to soft drinks manufacturers the
first-ever webcam was in the computer
lab at Cambridge University it was
permanently focused on the coffee pot in
the corridor to save the scientists for
making pointless trips when it had run
out there was a law in Sparta against
having an unmanly complexion palm trees
are a type of grass before humans
reached Hawaii the dominant animals were
giant dogs Winston Churchill was a druid
one in 11 people on earth earn their
money from tourism medieval peasants ate
about 4,000 calories per day twice as
many calories as the average person eats
today people are more likely to
cooperate with you if you give them
something warm to hold a grasshopper
becomes more sociable if you stroke its
hind legs one bull cropped is a
seventeenth-century word for indigestion
the amount of times you need to push
down per minute during CPR is the beat
of the song stayin alive or another one
bites the dust victorian slang for a
woman's breasts was Cupid's kettledrums
thanks for the view subscribe for more
thoughty2
you